quelques 300 députés français de tous
bords demande à jean castex de pouvoir
reprendre les débats sur l'euthanasie
dans un courrier au premier ministre il
demande d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour la
proposition de loi autorisant la
pratique ils demandent du temps
parlementaire
l'examen du texte porté par le député
olivier falorni et qui ouvre un droit à
une fin de vie libre est choisie n'a pas
pu aller à son terme en avril face aux
milliers d'amendements déposés par des
élus du groupe est républicain
plusieurs ministres parmi eux marlène
schiappa ou encore anne espagne et
relâchées ont apporté leur soutien on en
n'est pas tout de suite avec nos deux
invités de ce soir et nous sommes en
compagnie de corinne weis médecin en
soins palliatifs en belgique et rémi
tales fondateur de marianne un conseil
spécialisé en politique publique bonsoir
à tous les deux merci de participer à
cet échange ce soir rémi tales est ce
que ce débat parlementaire doit avoir
lieu sur un tel sujet de société
il est normal qu'ils aient un débat de
société sur ce sujet qui est un sujet
absolument fondamental ce débat doit
avoir lieu maintenant je ne crois pas je
suis un petit peu surpris et se disent
sans esprit polémique en mai par ce
calendrier cela fait plus d'un an
maintenant que le parlement vote
régulièrement des entraves aux libertés
ou non je cite un de la protection de la
vie et en 3e propos du président de la
république du principe selon lequel rien
est au dessus de la vie et on pousse
comme ça d'un seul coup sur l'euthanasie
je crois que le moment n'est pas
opportun pour entrer dans ce débat est
ce qu'au contraire ce contexte de crise
sanitaire avec ses nombreux morts dont
on fait des tas tous les soirs est ce
que justement le contexte ne justifie
pas qu'on repose la question de la fin
de vie alors je crois que le contexte
justifie qu'on s'interroge sur la
question de la fin de vie et je
regardais les chiffres avant de 2,2
d'intervenir
j'observe que si son lit par exemple de
soins palliatifs ont été supprimés ont
été fermés en france depuis deux ans je
discutais cet après midi avec lui une
infirmière en soins palliatifs qui me
disait le manque criant de moyens et la
difficulté de prise en charge le fait
dans ses services son refus de chaque
semaine des patients donc oui je crois
que
un vrai débat les sujets sur des
souffrances indicibles dont on ne
s'occupe pas assez
malgré la bonne volonté est vraiment
l'engagement des professionnels mais je
suis pas sûr que l'euthanasie soit la
bonne réponse à y apporter si vous
voulez il sent que ce serait une réponse
facile et expéditive face à un véritable
problème à vous comprendre.les corps
invest que le simple fait de prendre le
temps de débattre au parlement français
de cette question de société pose
question vous qui en belgique
autoriser l'euthanasie depuis 2002 mais
je pense que ça fait des années que
veulent en france le problème n'est pas
traité à fond les différentes lois qui
se sont succédé n'ont pas régler des
questions de fond c'est à dire que les
patients qui demande d'euthanasie
continuent à ne pas être entendus la
sédation terminale n'est pas la bonne
réponse mes collègues de soins
palliatifs ne sont pas favorables à ces
à ce type de de réponse parce que
effectivement c'est une euthanasie un
peu déguisés et lente
donc je pense qu'effectivement c'est
dommage que ça arrive à ce moment là
mais il faut il faut il faut il faut
faire ce débat en belgique ça fait 20
ans que la loi est là contrairement à
fkih régulièrement dix en france il n'y
a pas de dérive c'est à dire qu'on reste
toujours avec environ 2% des décès qui
sont pratiqués dans le cadre de
l'euthanasie ce qui est un chiffre très
bas par rapport par rapport à la mort et
et en plus nous avons intégré
l'euthanasie dans le cas des soins quoi
y est c'est à dire que nous accompagnons
les patients avec leur demande s'ils ne
demandent pas l'euthanasie bien sûr nous
faisons des soins palliatifs ordinaire
mais si il demande d'euthanasie ils ont
droit aux soins palliatifs et nous les
accompagnons dans cette demande avec la
procédure légale qui est une procédure
compliquée une procédure qui est qui
demande beaucoup d'engagement de la part
des soignants mais nous le faisons pour
respecter là
volonté du patient et parce que nous
savons où charron
en tant que médecin en soins palliatifs
que nous avons un ensemble de patients
pour qu'ils nous n'avons pas le choix
soit on les fait dormir à la fin soit on
l'a on leur donne l'euthanasie ce qui
leur permet de mourir entourés de leurs
proches de pas sont confiantes
alors on va en reparler justement cet
aspect médical mais quelles
répercussions en belgique delà de la
politique de fin de vie mené en france
est ce que les françaises se rendent de
plus en plus chez vous pour avoir accès
à l'euthanasie
que vous disent ce que vous accompagnez
peut-être mais moi je me refuse de
prendre des patients en français parce
que nous avons pas beaucoup ça nous
avons juste assez de place pour nos
patients belges donc c'est difficile on
sera éthique de prendre des patients
français mais j'ai des collègues qui le
font et c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué pour les patients c'est c'est
il faut qu'il fasse plusieurs
allers-retours donc ça coûte cher il
faut que leurs familles soient là donc
nous ne sommes pas du tout favorable à
ça nous trouvons que c'est pas notre job
que de que de d'accompagner des patients
français donc nous attendons avec
impatience qu'effectivement la france
prenne ses responsabilités c'est la même
chose pour mes collègues en suisse avec
le suicide médicalement assisté
ça n'est pas normal que les patients
doivent s'expatrier pour avoir droit à
l'euthanasie
rémi tales comment est-ce qu'on mettait
comment est-ce qu'on verra un terme à
cette situation des français qui doivent
se rendre à l'étranger pour l'euthanasie
c'est bien sinon qu'il faut trouver une
solution en france alors ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand promet une
meilleure application de la loi actuelle
dite leonetti loi léonetti qui prévoit
une sédation profonde et continue
pouvoir mener à la mort mais sans eau
tamasy active visiblement c'est pourtant
ce que recherche certains français alors
effectivement ce que je comprends c'est
que les décrets d'application de cette
loi ont été publiés c'est tardivement
cette loi clé ce les nantis elle a été
votée en 2016 il est décrit patrick
d'applications pardon été pris en 2018
et en 2019 peut-être devrait-on laisser
le temps faire son oeuvre afin de
s'assurer que la loi clean qui ne permet
pas déjà de répondre aux situations
existantes
j'insiste vraiment sur ce set
qui ont des moyens et la prise en charge
moi je les observais 500 très direct et
très très douloureuse de personnes qui
sont en fin de vie liés au cancer en
phase terminale et auquel on propose
d'aller aux urgences en france je ne
connais pas la situation en belgique et
en france aussi souvent comme ça que ça
se passe
il me semble qu'on devrait déjà réglé ce
problème sur l'enjeu des dérives madame
je ne veux évidemment pas que vous
fassiez formidablement bien votre
travail je note simplement deux chiffres
qui sont donnés par la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
qui indique que en belgique sur 208
patients qui étaient rentrés dans une
étude de 9 ans les patients qui ont été
le tan azilal paraît que 32% d'entre eux
n'avaient pas formulé de demande
explicite d'euthanasie autres chiffres
il apparaît que 46 % des patients qui
ont des ternésiens en belgique selon une
autre étude lorette et et suite à une
dépression
non je crois que ce sujet là un des
rouges aussi sur notre rapport à la mort
et sur la façon dont on intègre la
société dans la volonté que tout à
chacun peut avoir légitimement de mourir
mais la question c'est plutôt de savoir
est ce que l'état a le droit de donner
cette cette mort là et à se surpasser
mais je n'y crois pas qu'est ce que vous
répondez at l'accord entre ce suicide et
que ces chiffres sont totalement faux
alors il ya eu des études dans les
années 2005 2006 donc peu de temps après
la loi qui ont montré qu effectivement
il y avait des difficultés d'application
de la loi
juste quelques années après mais ces
chiffres sont faux actuellement dire
actuellement il n'y a pas de de gens qui
ont le talent asie alors qu'ils ne l'ont
pas demandé
c'est complètement faux je vais le
tamani c'est pas un acte graphique pour
un médecin
on ne fait pas une zone asie si les gens
ne demandent pas et en plus on doit
remplir des documents après il ya une
commission de contrôle et cette
commission vérifie qu effectivement
c'est bien le nom du patient ça doit
être une demande écrite et s est
contrôlé par des gens extérieurs
le médecin qui fait le terreau l'asie
ils vérifient peut il ya une demande
écrite
donc c'est effectivement l'acheter à
publier des des chiffres qui sont des
chiffres
au contre lequel nous nous sommes
insurgés en dix ans mais ça n'est pas
vrai la dépression il faut avoir c'est
faux il faut avoir une maladie mentale
donc ce n'est pas une simple dépression
qui peut nous faire avoir l'euthanasie
en béton et ses études ephe chiffres
sont faux la dimension morale de cette
question de la fin de vie sans vous
l'emportez en france sur le plan médical
vous vous commenciez à l'évoquer il ya
quelques instants corinne baisse au plan
médical justement quelle longueur est ce
que vous portez avec quelques années
d'expérience sur la législation belge
mais je pense que mes collègues médecins
ont beaucoup de mal à appliquer cette
loi en tout cas les soins palliatifs ont
beaucoup mal à appliquer cette loi les
tic laisse donc la deuxième loi parce
que effectivement on est en difficulté
d'un point de vue éthique quand un
patient demande la mort et que la seule
solution qu'on lui qu'on va lui proposer
c'est une sédation ci demande à mourir
ils ne vendent pas à dormir est demandée
et être mis dans le sommeil ça veut dire
rompre toute relation
ça veut dire mourir seul dans son
sommeil on n'a plus de contact avec ses
proches
donc les médecins sont très mal à l'aise
avec le fait de de poser un acte qui ne
correspond pas à la demande du patient
donc nous en belgique on est très claire
les gens donnent heureusement la dormir
on les fait dormir et ça on n'a pas
besoin de loi c'est le cadre des soins
palliatifs habituel on peut tout à fait
quand les gens sont en souffrance
silsilah ils l'acceptent
on peut tout à fait les faire dormir et
il ya un deuxième
une deuxième solution c'est que les
patients si les patients demande
d'euthanasie donc ils demandent à voir
une injection qui l'est qui les fait
mourir en étant conscient aulas on peut
le faire avec avec une loi qui est très
encadrée c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir
une souffrance insupportable
inapaisables est une maladie grave et
incurable qui est éprouvée par un autre
médecin que celui qui qui qui pratique
d'un lit et qui entend l'allemand la
demande doit être répétée réfléchit sans
pression extérieure
on doit avoir la vie positive de
l'équipe soignante on doit s'entretenir
avec les proches
donc c'est un contexte de
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
qui est ce qui est celui de l'euthanasie
alors effectivement c'est difficile pour
les médecins donc je sais bien que mes
collègues de soins palliatifs en france
ont très peur de ça mais on peut faire
des bons soins palliatifs et ne pas
pratiquer l'euthanasie mais on peut
aussi faire des bons soins palliatifs et
écouter les rares patients et sont rares
2%
c'est ce n'est pas beaucoup 2 % des
décès s'est pas beaucoup
et alors nous avons eu la chance en
belgique que les deux lois sont passés
en même temps ça ira loi qui garantit
l'accès aux soins palliatifs et la loi
qui autorise qui dépénalise automne asie
les deux lois sont passés en même temps
alors justement à venir le pour revenir
qu'est ce que malheureusement le temps
nous manque que rémi tales pour revenir
sur la dimension politique de cette
question de société
est ce que c'est un sujet qui peut se
prêter à un débat de campagne électorale
comment est ce que vous voyez les
nombreux amendements qui ont été déposés
par le groupe l'est républicain sur ce
texte porté par olivier falorni d'un mot
s'il vous plaît ça ces enjeux de
politique classique en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que si la france décidé de
lever l'interdît de tuer qui tremble
interdit fondamental depuis les guides
de l'humanité il faudrait que ce débat
chacun puisse y prendre part et donc
évidemment l'élection présidentielle est
l'occasion privilégiée pour le faire et
c'est un débat qui mérite évidemment
davantage de temps on a déjà eu
l'occasion de dd de mettre en avant
certaines problématiques merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à cet échange
encore invest médecin en soins
palliatifs en belgique et rémi tales
fondateur de marianne conseil spécialisé
en politique qui pique